pour à tous et bienvenue ici à hawaï
donc aujourd'hui c'est un dimanche matin
et je reprends le taf
après un mois de vacances à hawaii c'est
plutôt que des vacances en fait
aujourd'hui en particulier je vais un
workshop 9 qui est un gros club autour
de la sécurité en intelligence
artificielle et qui lié à une non
conférence en machine learning qui
s'appelle triponez gatineau artificielle
et vous avez insistera également à la
cour et à la conférence et si ça va le
faire un espèce de blogs pour essayer de
lui donner une idée de comment
fonctionne le groupe de la recherche
[Musique]
alors les conférences c'est surtout
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
présentations de chercheurs de leurs
derniers travaux et en informatique
c'est un peu particulier parce que c'est
en fait extrêmement prestigieux pour
pouvoir avoir une telle présentation
faut avoir écrit un papier qui a été
relu par les pairs et qui a été
sélectionné par les pairs comme étant un
papier qui mérite le fait d'être
présenté dans la conférence
alors ça c'est vraiment les tops paquet
qui ont le droit à une telle
présentation ce qu'ils soient un peu
moins bon ont le droit à des posters
c'est à dire que le paquet sera acceptée
la publication mais les auteurs du
paquet ne pourront pas le présenter dans
une session ils pourront en revanche
avoir un poster qui sera présenté lors
des séances de poster qui sont vraiment
d'ailleurs vraiment la folie un triplé à
ya notamment parce que c'est un peu
petit mais il y avait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de gens et c'était vraiment
passionnant à c'est vraiment pour moi
j'avais l'impression de marcher dans un
musée avec des oeuvres d'art à gauche à
droite et avec les artistes qui sont
capables de décrire le contenu de leurs
offres et en plus le contenu des heures
et 13 heures relativement solide
techniquement et scientifiquement et on
pourra c'est vraiment une occasion
absolument génial pour nous tenir à jour
de la recherche en intelligence
artificielle mais les conférences ce
n'est bien sûr pas que ça ce sont
beaucoup de discussions informelles de
gens que l'on rencontre et que l'on
revoie d'une conférence à l'autre tu
occasions notamment de revoir d'anciens
collègues de bureau om et il y a quatre
ans et c'est assez marrant de le voir
ici
et puis les conférences c'est aussi
l'occasion aussi et surtout de réseauter
et oui un peu comme tout professionnel
les chercheurs ont besoin de se faire un
réseau de connaissances ça aide
énormément pourquoi ensuite pouvoir
développer des collaborations pour
pouvoir ensuite mieux être informés de
ce qui se passe dans le domaine pour
avoir de meilleures idées des prochaines
recherches à faire est de se faire une
meilleure idée de quels sont les sujets
de recherche qui rompt le plus de
chances d'être acceptée lors des
prochaines conférences et c'est un petit
peu cynique et ce que j'entends dire
mais c'est aussi l'occasion juste
d'avoir un bon moment entre des gens
intéressés souvent juste extrêmement
curieux tous partageant une passion peu
une commune pour la recherche le savoir
scientifique et faire tout cela autour
d'une bière
alors bien sûr il faut boire avec
modération et tout ça mais partager des
bons moments autour d'une bière c'est
quelque chose qui n'a pas de prix
d'ailleurs la conférence tripoli ya
justement cherché à organiser beaucoup
de tels événements pour que les
chercheurs puissent se rencontrer et
dialoguer lieu aussi quelques
conférences heures en plénière d'hier
avec tout le monde qui a ouvert au monde
pour essayer de fédérer toute la
communauté de recherche indigence
artificiel autour des grandes
problématiques de l'intelligence
artificielle notamment sur le plus ou
moins long terme et j'étais assez
content de voir qu'ils étaient souvent
question d'éthique
même si j'ai été un petit peu déçu de
voir que ce n'était pas le sujet
principal est qu'il ya encore énormément
de progrès à faire en tout cas se noie
comment aussi insisté sur cette image
qui est assez assez fabuleuse où les
rôles sont un petit peu inversés parce
que tu dans l'informatique pareil
beaucoup lui donne
tellement de vieilles personnes blanches
les personnes guéries personnes blanches
mais voilà c'est un petit peu le cliché
de professeurs visuel qui fait la leçon
aux autres le rôle a été inversée
notamment vraiment dans ses compétences
où il ya eu de plus en plus de femmes
dans les milieux notamment ici une table
ronde où c'est vraiment par accident qui
et trois femmes s'étaient pas du tout
prévu c'était pas du tout par efforts
d'égalité homme femme
c'est juste que c'est ce sont les trois
personnes qui ont les articles les mieux
développés ou du moins son étroit
réseauteur de trois articles acceptés
dans le domaine des attaques adverses
herald une machine learning et c'était
assez amusant tout cas voire surprenant
mais vraiment plaisant de voir que les
rôles se sont un petit peu inversés lors
de cette table ronde
bref pendant cette petite semaine je me
suis bien éclaté j'ai beaucoup appris et
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup réfléchi du coup
je remercie triplé y aller pour
l'organisation de cet événement et en
particulier le workshop syfy pour avoir
accepté le premier et pour m'avoir donné
cette opportunité de côtoyer ce qui se
fait de mieux dans la recherche propre
intelligence artificielle
bah voilà c'est fini en fin de
conférence par un peu plus tôt c'est
fatigant c'est chouette des confiance
dernière chose avant de vous laisser
sachez que j'ai fait un long retour
d'expérience sur la chaîne dax techno
prog et kim interviews et ou du coup je
suis passé en long en large et en
travers sur tout ce que j'ai appris
pendant cette conférence dont il ya pas
tous tour l'interview ne dure qu'une
heure mais il y aura beaucoup
d'informations pour tous ceux parmi vous
qui sont intéressés par la recherche en
intelligence artificielle et notamment
par les questions de sécurité et
d'éthique des ja